yeah hello to this video welcome to this
video I think it's welcome to this video
right okay so playing tacticals out for
the reverse chrome Priam yeah why do
people know stuff and that's no good
they are more read those books and just
reproduce stuff yeah I have to admit I
do this as well so yeah okay what do
you--what you played there is a pretty
annoying line and something that I have
and I only know that this is probably
good for white but I don't don't know
how black should react that reverse
Grand Prix is um yeah just one of my
sorry one of my um of the openings that
are only playing blitz games I don't
really trust it enough to play in
tournament chess yeah so I lost some
time here and my pawn structure might be
might be ashame yeah I was thinking III
is a move yeah I'm going for that it's
pretty weird but my idea is that if I go
nite f2 next I can go on f4 even this
and then f4 because the night has no
squares isn't that an idea okay but if I
not move my knight III is hanging with
check okay
ok I have to do that anyway one f/4g
takes and I have no square for my night
that it's not a check night at five okay
but that leaves a straight away okay g5
traps us night but what a weird game
I don't see a good continuation here
maybe i'm just-just word i mean it
certainly can certainly possible mf1
text i have f naught square for that
night 95's night text e5 it doesn't make
any sense
no I probably just losing for Blackfoot
I mean yeah I mean this is losing but I
had no head no had nothing I had nothing
that I can do was kind of funny how that
went why can take on g6 what a [ __ ]
game oh wow breaking code t5 this is
just terrible now KD 5 I might take the
night ok well Queen f2 I can maybe take
a for vets now not really you can take
on g6 is going back there
hey Eli he wants to move the Queen away
and go in for him that would be nice
yeah or this one can I get then it's
maybe I can somehow irritate them it's
not really great or anything but maybe
you can go see five here
vote for Knight f6 mmm not i don't care
i cannot prevent it anyway so check so
how to do this maybe he M Queen d4
Knight f5 is maybe something Quincy for
Bishop g2 93 wins they exchange back and
then I'm what it is still it's tough
down I can also go to f 21 what they are
okay
hmm going back it's no good it's tough
to go forward okay
time warning okay black resigns oh
pretty pretty awful game again yeah this
is one of those kids i have three that
was Jim I just doesn't book what can you
do I mean I was thinking along these
lines look here and then at four and I
move the night and decides no squares
but III hangs with check and this is of
course the technical reason why all this
is not working and also the reason why I
my position is bad because if I have to
take then why does just of course a lot
better yeah I don't know medium I have
to discard that line for even for blitz
chess sometimes even decent players have
no recipe against it and just get into
bed positions with white but if they
know what they're doing and why it is
just better or I need to study it for
real and for just some some some blitz
opening let's say I only didn't want to
study it and against this kind of awful
games like that yeah probably better to
play some some real opening there and
not some nonsense like the Grand Prix
reversed I mean it's not completely
terrible but then you really have to
know it and not just kind of go down
whenever the opponent plays on a main
theoretical line pretty awful game
thanks for watching